MARCO GUTIERREZ GIRALDO:
My name is Marco.
And my org is Robocomp.
Robocomp is a
framework for robotics,
which has the basic
tools for developers
and a set of components, so you
can run your own robot with it.
It's written in C++.
Robocomp has been
around since 2000.
It's been like quite
a few years now.
It started at the University
of Extremadura in Spain.
It was a project by the
robotics lab over there.
And now, it's getting bigger.
And there's a lot
of universities
from Spain involved in it.
And they're using it and
developing stuff for it.
I got a job at the university.
And right now, I'm
getting my PhD.
So I do some research
with the project.
This our first year at
the Google Summer of Code.
It's been a really, really
good experience for us.
We got two slots, two students.
And they turned out to be great.
One, well, actually,
both of them
are today working with us,
even if the program is over.
So we are really happy
with the experience.
Robocomp has got a simulator.
And that's one of
our main tools.
So we got a student that
started working with it.
And he put some physics
in it, because we
were missing that part.
And now, we're able
to simulate the world
in a more accurate way.
And then we had
another student that
was working on the deployment
part of the framework.
So she built a tool for
managing all the components
that you can have in a robot.
So we have now a nice GUI, so
you can just start and stop
the robot with a single click.
We will actually get
pretty much anyone there,
because we have tons of stack
of tasks that anyone can do.
So I would say they just
need to like robotics and be
interested in it.
But, yeah, if they
know some programming,
and they just want
to get involved,
it's free for everyone to
come by and drop us an email
and say, hey, can I help you?
Yeah, we're always
willing to help people.
In Robocomp, we're
interested in people
that have a passion
for robotics and that
want to learn and
to do some research.
So pretty much anyone
that is interested
can just come by and
drop us an email.
Our URL is Robocomp.org.
So they can just go
to a web browser,
get there, and get
the information.
And we'll be happy to help them.
The biggest win for Robocomp
was that we got more open.
We got people from all
over to work with us.
We got some documentation going
on, and it's getting better.
So I guess it made
us more open source.